I had been considering standing,
and I got preparations in place,
and I was still on the fence.
And then the majority of the Irish MPs voted to opt in
to the European assailment migration pact.
I believe this was totally the wrong decision, uh,
for Ireland.
And I believe it just shows you how disconnected the Irish MPs are
with the people in Ireland.
Uh, we cannot, uh,
support an additional 26,000 asylum seekers in Ireland at the moment.
We have stepped up to the plate and we've brought in over a.
Supported over 105,000 Ukrainian refugees.
We, uh,
do not have the infrastructure in rural Ireland
to bring in an additional 26,000 asylum seekers.
We don't have the guarded to support it.
We don't have the hospitals to support it,
and we definitely, definitely don't have the houses to accommodate.
So that's why I decided to stand.